hello everyone I'm Chris Botts Welcome
to our unit on contextual word
representations I thought I'd kick this
off with some high level guiding ideas
the first thing I wanted to say is that
in previous iterations of this course we
spent about two weeks focused on static
Vector representations of words and in
some cases phrases and full sentences
for this iteration of the course we're
going to go directly to contextual word
representations which have proven so
powerful for today's NLP research and
Technologies but I did want to offer a
brief overview of the history that leads
to contextual representations so let's
rewind the clock back to what I've
called feature-based classical lexical
representations and the Hallmark of
these representations that is that they
are sparse typically what we're thinking
of is very long vectors where the column
Dimensions represent the output of
usually hand-built feature functions
that we've written that might capture
things like the binary sentiment
classification of a word or which part
of speech it tends to have most
dominantly or whether or not it ends in
a suffix like ing for English and so
forth and so on so we write a lot of
these feature functions and as a result
we have vectors that are mostly zeros
because most words don't have these
properties but the few ones carry
important information
in the next phase we have count based
methods this is the introduction of the
distributional hypothesis I'm thinking
of methods like pointwise Mutual
information and TF IDF term frequency
inverse document frequency a classic
from information retrieval that we'll
visit a bit later in the course
for these methods We Begin from some
kind of count Matrix so typically for
PMI it would be a word by word Matrix
where the cells in that Matrix capture
the number of time so that each word
co-occurs with the other words in our
Corpus for TF IDF it would probably be a
word by document Matrix and now we're
capturing which words appear and with
what frequency in all the documents in
our Corpus and the idea behind these
methods is that we take PMI or TF IDF
and we massage those counts in a way
that leads to better representations
and that's coming purely from
distributional information we typically
don't write hand-built feature functions
in this mode but these vectors tend to
be pretty sparse
the next phase is what I've called
classical dimensionality reduction this
is the introduction of dense
representations I have in mind methods
like PCA principal components analysis
SVD that singular value decomposition
LDA is latent dirichlet allocation
there's a whole family of these and
typically what we're doing at this phase
is taking maybe the output of
representations built in the mode of
step two there and compressing them and
encompressing them we typically get
denser more informative representations
that can also capture higher order
Notions of distributional similarity and
co-occurrence and so forth and that
proved incredibly powerful
and then the fourth phase which might be
the final phase for this static Vector
representation approach we have what
I've called learn dimensionality
reduction approaches here again we have
dense representations these could be the
output of an auto encoder or a classical
method like word to VEC or glove and
what we do at this phase is really
essentially combine the count based
methods from step two in this history
with the dimensionality reduction
reduction that we see for methods like
SVD and PCA and that leads us to very
powerful typically learned
representations that have a tremendous
capacity to capture higher order Notions
of co-occurrence
that's a very fast overview if you would
like to get Hands-On with these methods
and really deeply understand them then
check out this page that I've linked to
here from the course website it links to
a lot of notebooks and some older videos
that help could help you with a
refresher on all these methods or to
just get up to speed where you're ready
to think directly about contextual
representations
the representations that we get from
these contextual models that will be the
focus for this unit and really for the
entire course really resonate with me as
a linguist and so I thought I would just
pause here and run through some examples
that I think lead from the Linguistics
angle to the conclusion that word
representations are highly sensitive to
the context in which they're used let's
start with a simple case like the vase
broke and our Focus will be on that
English verb break here the sense of
break is something like shatter
for Dawn broke though we have a
superficially similar looking sentence
subject verb but now the sense of break
is more like begin
and that's presumably conditioned by
what we know about the subject and how
that operates on the sense of the verb
break for a stereotypical reading the
news broke again superficially similar
sentence the news is the subject but now
it seems to be conditioning a reading
that is more like
um was announced or appeared or was
published very different sense yet again
for Sandy Brook the record we have our
first transitive case and now the sense
of break is something like surpass the
previous world record
but for Sandy broke the law a different
sense yet again this is something like a
transgression again conditioned in this
case by the direct object the burglar
broke into the house now we have break
appearing with a particle into and in
this case it means like enter forcibly
without permission but the newscaster
broke into the movie Broadcast means
something more like interrupt a related
but interestingly distinct meaning that
is coming from the same break plus
particle Construction
and then in we broke even
just for another surprise this is an
entirely new sense break plus even means
something like we lost the same amount
as we gained
and this is just a sample of the many
many senses that break can take on in
English and what we see in these
patterns is that the sense it does have
in context is driven by the surrounding
words transparently but maybe also by
things that are happening in the context
similar things arise first come
adjectives like flat as in flat beer
flat note flat tire flat surface that's
the same adjective flat but depending on
what noun it modifies you get very
different senses can happen with a verb
to throw a party throw a fight throw a
ball throw a fit there might be some
metaphorical sense in which these all of
these senses are related but they are
also clearly distinct and they're being
driven by something about how this
direct object interacts with the verb
and we should extend this Beyond just
the simple morphosyntactic context let's
think about ambiguity resolution coming
from the things we say to each other
for the sentence a crane caught a fish
you probably inferred that they are the
sense of crane is for a bird it's not
determined by that but that's the most
likely inference whereas a clay a crane
picked up the steel beam you probably
infer in that case that a crane is a
machine and then correspondingly for I
saw a crane you might not absent more
context know whether I mean a bird or a
machine but if we do embed this sentence
in larger context you'll begin to make
inferences about whether it was a bird
or a machine and so that shows you that
even things that are happening ambiently
in the context of utterance can impact
what the set what sense crane has in
these sentences
are there any typos I didn't see any the
second sentence is clearly elliptical
and in this case we probably infer that
I didn't see any means I didn't see any
typos contrast that with are there any
bookstores downtown I didn't see any
it's an identical second sentence but
now the inference is that any means
something like any bookstores
and that is again showing that the
senses that these words take on in
context could be driven by everything
that is happening in the surrounding
sentence and also in the surrounding
discourse on out extending into things
about World Knowledge and so forth
and so that for me really shows that the
static word Vector representation
approach was never really going to work
out because it insists that broke in all
those examples in one correspond to a
single Vector flat into a has to be a
single vector and so forth and so on and
what we actually see in how language
works is much more malleability for
individual word meanings and that's
precisely what contextual word
representations allow us to capture
I thought I would pause here just to
offer a brief history of where these
ideas come from because it's a very
recent history uh things are moving fast
but it's also interesting to track I
think a classic paper maybe the starting
point for this is die in Lay 2015 they
really showed the value of language
model style pre-training for Downstream
tasks and the paper is fascinating to
look at it's a pre-transformer paper a
lot of the things that they do look
complicated in retrospect and some of
the simpler ideas that they offer we can
now see in retrospect are incredibly
powerful
we fast forward a little bit to August
2017 McCann at all this is the Cove
paper and what they showed is that
pre-trained bi-directional lstms for
machine translation could offer us
sequence representations that were a
useful starting point for many other
Downstream tasks outside of Mt
and that kind of begins this move toward
pre-training for contextual
representations it really takes off with
Elmo in February 2018 they were that
team was really the first to show that
very large-scale pre-training of
bi-directional lstms could lead to Rich
multi-purpose representations that were
easily adapted to lots of Downstream
tasks via fine tuning
in June 2018 we get GPT and then in
October 2018 The Bert era truly begins
Devlin at all 2019 is when the paper was
published but the work appeared before
that and had already had tremendous
influence by the time it was actually
officially published that Bert model is
really the corridor Stone of so much
that we'll discuss in this unit and
Beyond
there's a parallel Dimension to all this
a kind of parallel Journey that I
thought I would talk a little bit about
as another guiding idea I've put this
under the heading of model structure and
linguistic structure and this is related
also to this idea of what kinds of
structural biases we build into our
model architectures in the upper left I
have a simple model that's reviewed in
those background materials where you can
imagine that each word in the sentence
the Rock Rules is looked up in like a
glove space or a word that word to Vex
space and then what this model does is
simply add those representations
together to get a representation for the
entire sentence
this is a very high bias model in
particular because we have to decide
ahead of time that the way those
representations will combine will be via
addition and you have to think even if
that's approximately correct it's only
going to be approximate it would be a
kind of minor miracle if addition turned
out to be actually the optimal way to
combine those word meanings
and you could see that as giving rise to
the models that are on the right here
this is a kind of recurrent neural
network again you can imagine that we
look up each one of those words in a
static Vector representation space like
glove
but now we feed them into this RNN
process that actually process them
processes them with a bunch of new
neural network parameters and in that
way it could be trained it could be
taught to combine those word meanings in
an optimal way
it could be the case that the optimal
way to combine word meanings is with
addition and the models that we have
over here on the right are certainly
powerful enough to learn addition of
those vectors if it's correct but that
is very unlikely to happen probably the
model will learn a much more complicated
function that might be much more nuanced
and so in that way we've released some
of the biases that we introduced over
here and we're going to allow ourselves
to learn in a more free-form way from
data about how to optimally combine
words
there's another dimension to this if you
go down on the left here this is a tree
structured neural network in this case
we decide ahead of time that we know the
constituent structure
and then we might have a bunch of neural
network parameters that combine the
child nodes to create representations
for the parents in a recursive fashion
as we move up the tree
that is very powerful in the sense that
we could have lots of different
functions that get learned for how to
combine child nodes into their parents
but this model is kind of high bias
because it decides ahead of time about
how the constituent structure should
look you have to believe or know at
priori that the rock forms a constituent
in a way that Rock Rules simply does not
whereas the models up here take a more
free form approach
down in the right hand corner I have the
kind of models that we saw in the lead
up to the Transformer this could be like
a bi-directional RNN where again we
could look up the words in a static
Vector representation space but now we
have information flowing left to right
in these hidden representations and we
might have added a bunch of attention
mechanisms on top that essentially
connect every other hidden unit to every
other hidden unit in this representation
so whereas this had a presumption that
we would process left to right and this
one had an assumption that we would
process by constituent structure this
model down here says essentially
anything goes and I think it's fair to
say that a lesson of the Transformer era
is that anything goes given sufficient
data is the most powerful mode to be in
and that really is a kind of insight
behind the Transformer architecture
the attention mechanisms that I
mentioned there are really important and
this is also part of the journey that
leads us to the Transformer and might
Harbor most of its power let me give you
a simple example of how attention worked
especially in the lead up to
Transformers here I have a model that
you might think of as an RNN maybe we're
processing left to right for really not
so good we look up those words in some
kind of static Vector representation
space and then we have our left to right
process that leads to these hidden
representations suppose now that I want
to train a classifier on top of this
final output state
well I might worry in doing that that
there'll be a lot of information about
the words that are laid in the sequence
but not enough information in this
representation here about the words that
were earlier in the sequence and so
attention emerges as a kind of way to
remind ourselves in late States what was
in earlier ones
we could do that with a scoring function
and here what I've depicted is a simple
dot product scoring function exactly the
sort that we get from the transformer in
essence and what it's doing is taking
the dot product of our Target
representation with all of the previous
hidden States
we softmax normalize those and then we
kind of bring those in to the
representation that we are targeting to
get a context Vector here we could take
the average of all of them
then finally we get this attention
combination H here and that could be a
kind of neural network parameterized
function that takes in this
representation plus the attention
representation that we created here and
feeds that through some parameters and a
non-linearity and that finally gives us
the representation that we feed into the
classifier that we wanted to fit
originally and the idea here is that now
our classification decision is based
indeed on this representation at the end
but now infused with a lot of
information about how similar that
representation is to the ones that
preceded it and that is the essential
idea behind dot product attention which
will be the beating heart so to speak of
the Transformer
another idea that has proved so powerful
is a notion of sub word modeling and I
thought I would take you on a brief
journey of how we arrived in the current
phase for this kind of sub word modeling
beginning with Elmo because what Elmo
did is truly fascinating the Elmo word
representation space begins with
character level representations
and then it has a bunch of filters on
top of those and then it has a bunch of
different convolutional layers that we
then do Max pooling over to get a
representation for the entire sequence
we do that at different layers here and
so those get concatenated up into these
Max pooling representations at the top
and those form the basis for word
representations and the idea is that
this gives us whole word vectors that
nonetheless have lots of information
about the sub word Parts all the way
down to characters but including all of
these convolutions of different lengths
that capture different Notions of sub
word within that space incredibly
Visionary I would say
one thing I should note though is that
the Elmo vocabulary has about a hundred
thousand words in it which is an
enormous vocabulary and even still if
you deal with real text you will find
that you are mostly encountering words
that are not in that vocabulary and even
if you double it to two hundred thousand
or three hundred thousand now you're
getting a really large embedding space
you will still mostly encounter words
that are unked out that is unknown to
your model and that's an incredibly
limiting factor for this kind of whole
word approach but we see in here the
essence of the idea that we should model
sub words
a big change happened for the
Transformer when we got in parallel this
notion of word peace tokenization
here I'm going to give you a feel for
that by looking at the Bert tokenizer
that gets loaded in and sent in cell 2
here and then when we call the tokenizer
on the sentence this isn't too
surprising we get things that look
mostly like whole words especially if
you're used to NLP where the kind of
suffix for isn't has been broken apart
and so is the punctuation
but when we call the tokenizer on the
sequence encode me with an exclamation
mark notice that the word encode has
been split apart into do two words N and
then code with those markers there
indicating that that is a word internal
piece
and if you tokenize a word like
Snuffleupagus
you get a sequence of one two three four
five six parts to that single word that
came in
the effect here is that we can have a
vanishingly small vocabulary there are
under thirty thousand words in this
tokenization space so a very small
embedding space but nonetheless when we
encounter words that are outside of that
space they don't get unknked out but
rather we analyze them into sub word
pieces that we do have embedding
representations for
incredibly powerful and in the context
of a contextual model we might have some
hope that for cases like and code being
split into two tokens the model will
learn internally that in some sense
those form a coherent piece a word but
we don't need that directly reflected in
the tokenizer's vocabulary
incredible idea
a related idea for the Transformer that
is so foundational and that I think the
field is still figuring out is
positional encoding when we talk about
the Transformer you will see that it has
almost no way of keeping track of the
order of words in a sequence it's mostly
a bunch of columns of different things
that happen independently with some
attention mechanisms bringing them
together
so to capture word order we typically
have something like positional encoding
the most heavy-handed way to do that is
to Simply have in addition to your word
embedding space a positional embedding
space that simply records where
individual words appear in the sequence
so here that is paired with one because
it's at the start of the sequence but if
thou was in position four it would be
this fixed Vector here combined with the
embedding for position four and those
get added together into what you might
think of as the basis for contextual
representation
this has proved effective but it has
many limitations that we're going to
talk about later in the unit and we're
going to explore ways to capture what's
good about positional encoding while
also overcoming some of the problems
that it introduces
and then of course one of the major
guiding ideas behind all of this is
simply massive scale pre-training this
is an idea that was unlocked by the
distributional hypothesis which had the
Insight that we don't need to write
hand-built feature functions but rather
we can just rely on unlabeled corpora
and keep track of which words are
appearing with which other words
it really comes into its own in the
neural ERA with models like word to VEC
and glove as I mentioned
following that we get the Elmo paper and
I mentioned before that that was the
eye-opening moment when we saw that we
could learn contextual representations
at scale and have that transfer into
tasks we wanted to fine-tune for
and of course you get the GPT paper and
then Bert launches The Bert era
and then you get at the end of this
little history here the gpt3 paper which
applied this massive scale idea at a
level that was previously unimagined and
unimaginable and that really did
introduce a phase change in research as
we started to deal with these truly
massive models and ask them to learn in
context that is just from prompts we
offer them how to perform tasks and so
forth
and then related to this of course is
the idea of fine-tuning and its
corresponding notion of pre-training
here's a brief review of these ideas
in 2016 to 2018 the notion of
pre-training that we had was essentially
that we would feed static word
representations into variants of rnns
and then the model would be fine-tuned
and it would learn a bunch of stuff
when we fast forward to The Bert era in
2018 we start to get fine-tuning of
contextual models and here is just a bit
of code of A Sort that you will write in
this course where we read invert
representations and fine-tune them
essentially to be a classifier
that started in 2018 and I think it
continues we might be headed into an era
in which most of the fine-tuning that
happens is on these massive language
models that we mostly don't have access
to so we can't write code as in the Bert
code there but rather we just call an
API and some kind of partially
understood and partially known to us
fine-tuning process fine-tune some of
the parameters for one of these large
models to do what we want to do I'm
hoping that we still see a lot more of
this custom code being written it's very
powerful analytically and
technologically but this is surely part
of your future as an NLP or as well